tonight I'm going to talk about what I'm
calling the modern web and I mean that
from a user's experience as well as the
developer's experience so I'll try to
refer to that back and forth basically I
want to talk about how this rich
JavaScript ecosystem developed and kind
of some of the big milestones along the
way and then I'll show a couple samples
of how that used to look and how it
looks today a little bit about me I work
at VMware I am a user interface engineer
on the clarity design team and the
clarity design system is a toolkit of UI
guidelines and resources as well as a UI
JavaScript HTML component library and
then the really advanced components are
actually written in angular so that you
can add data and functionality and
really make them work with an angular
app internally they're heavily used
throughout VMware's products so we kind
of evolved the project with a focus on
the enterprise and that kind of led us
to take a different approach to our
design system because we were starting
on the desktop and degrading for mobile
because most of our customers work on a
desktop so that kind of influence some
of the design choices we made along the
way so a little more about me I started
writing JavaScript I don't know around
2004 or 2005 and this was back in the
day when there wasn't any modern
frameworks there wasn't any one way to
do things and let's see as I moved
through my career I started working with
different people and when I started up a
group out in Westlake Village they just
wanted just like minded people who
wanted to meet up I often got questions
about why is it so complicated actually
sorry I'm gonna back up I messed up so
tonight we're gonna talk about the
history and where JavaScript came from
we're gonna look at some of the dev
tools that have evolved to help the
developer experience
and then I'm gonna walk through what I
call this timer app which is a simple
application that has you know some
specifications we could talk about and
then show you how it could have been
written ten or fifteen years ago and I
can script five or earlier show you how
you can turn it into more modern syntax
with es6 and then I'll try to walk
through a high level of what that could
look like as an angular application in
today's ecosystem so back when I started
really trying to meet like-minded folks
and and hang out with them
I'd have conversations with some of the
people who showed up to the meetup out
in Westlake Village and they'd say
things like you know why is the web so
complicated or I'm here I'm an engineer
but I'm a back-end engineer and I hate
JavaScript or you know has anyone ever
heard someone say I just want to use
jQuery in in a way that says it's not a
good thing to be using jQuery for what
they're trying to do so that's kind of
who this this is for people who are new
to web development there are people who
are voluntarily
have a lot to chew off and a lot to
understand why things are the way they
are so this will hopefully walk us
through how we got to here you know we
have things that people may be familiar
with there's backbone j/s knockout
angularjs angular react view we have
JavaScript es6 typescript babel web pack
gulp grunt and many many more that I
didn't put on the slide even more than
that there's so much out there there's
no way any one person can be an expert
or even know kind of all the tools so we
got here you know by a couple different
important evolutions in JavaScript and I
think it's important to understand those
so that as you are bombarded with new
tools every day you can kind of say you
know what kind of niche does this fill
and where did it come from
you know what drove
evolution of this tool I'm using and the
way I see it you know JavaScript has had
a 20-plus year evolution and it has
really five four or five phases or eras
we could call them in the beginning it
was very simple HTML CSS JavaScript
throw it on a web server you're good
then things got a little more
complicated users want a little more
functionality in their app it'll got a
little more difficult for a couple
reasons we'll outline in a minute but
jQuery came along and kind of helped
solve those problems it helped really
address some developer pain points and
made things a little better for the end
users of those apps but jQuery had some
problems to the morgue I used the more
pain that developers had using it and
you know the some really smart developer
said we can do better than this so what
I call frameworks part one came about
and these projects really helped kind of
organize code bases organize teams
around concepts and design patterns and
then make it you know a better developer
experience make apps a little bit closer
to native a native app which users were
really coming to expect around this time
in the evolution and then I put tooling
in between frameworks and the two
framework parts mainly because it needs
a home but it involves kind of along the
same time as the the frameworks one and
two there's a lot going on during that
time and so we'll look at some of those
tools and kind of how they they look in
practice and then we'll we'll end up the
history lesson with in frameworks part
two I'll look at two of the big big
heavyweights in the industry today and
then we'll go to a demonstration I have
of looking at that timer app three
different ways so way back when where
did where did it where did it begin in
1989 Tim berners-lee created the World
Wide Web he he started sharing documents
with his friends around the world and
making new friends kind of laying the
foundation for what the web could become
and he did it with HTML and CSS you know
it a little bit information a little bit
of style it wasn't real pretty by
today's standards but it was you know
leaps and bounds ahead of what anything
else was at the time and that lasted for
a couple years and folks started kind of
expecting a little bit more out of the
web pages or products needed to do a
little more with their web pages collect
information submit forms other things
had to be you know people said what if
we could do that and in a short two-week
burst I think around 1995 or so Brendan
Eich coded up JavaScript and you know
here we are today but it all really
started in the evolution of JavaScript
you know that two-week period and it
enabled a lot of things that created a
lot of problems but those problems got
solved and and new new tools were built
to address those problems so it was
actually a really exciting time whom
though by today's standards you know a
1995 website probably looks pretty
pretty arcane right now so some of the
problems that they had were around the
issues with standards and the need to do
the same functionality for addressing
multiple browsers and you know that was
a big big pain point for developers
because they spent all their time coding
a feature five eight ten different ways
depending on how many browsers were out
there that they wanted to support and
the browser's weren't crap cooperating
because there's some nascent standards
committees out there but the browser's
didn't implement the standards the same
way so you know it had a lot of problems
for developers and they solved them they
got through it but they needed another
tool in around 2005 or so I think John
John Resig was his name he's the initial
creator of jQuery and there are a couple
other tools out there at the time that
are worth mentioning hmm my notes are
gone
but the tools that I remember are Yui
framework the MU tools I think prototype
was another tool that tried to solve
these problems in a way that developers
didn't have to worry about browsers they
could abstract the layer on top of the
the code that would work and then the
client delivered to the browser would
figure out how to address each browser
quirk as it as it is probably called but
jQuery did five things really really
well and it really enabled a massive
adoption and the first thing that it did
really really well is it exposed
something called the jQuery object and
this was a thing that no matter what
else jQuery would do for you it let you
extend it it let you build your own
functionality so when you use jQuery and
it solves some of those other problems
but you had a new problem you could
write your own custom solution in jQuery
style and plug that into your app
without having to worry about the
browser quirks the the other things that
were going on the other thing it enabled
with plugins is it was really the first
time I saw a massive sharing of these
tools people were saying well we solve
this dropdown menu issue and now if you
want to drop down menu you can go to the
there was a sort of a pseudo repository
of jQuery plugins you could look for
something see who was developing it and
and use it in their your projects and
maybe even contribute back to it in the
early days before github so that was one
of the big things that I think helped
jQuery become the de-facto tool that
developers used when they really started
looking for some structure and
organization in their apps and then the
second thing they did is they
standardized Dom access they made it
very simple to find an element and do
things to it and they did it in a way
that abstracted above almost all of the
browser quirks that were causing
developers to not waste time but spend a
lot of time making sure their app was
performed
and working in a wide variety of
browsers I think that one was really
important event handlers is a similar
pattern to the Dom access but basically
they provided a standard way to find
elements attach functionality to those
elements and have it and not have to
worry about it working in one browser
and not another browser so those
standard Wars drove a lot of what the
fundamentals of jQuery saw problems that
they solved the first thing it did is it
baked in simple animations you know hide
and show slide up slide down etc if
you've ever seen an app that does that
jQuery provided an easy way to do that
and it did two things it made it easier
for developers to add some polish to
their apps and it also kind of started
to raise users expectations for what the
web could become like it wasn't just a
toy anymore when it looked and behaved a
little more like a native app it was
actually kind of cool to work on it it
was kind of cooler to use it and a
little more fun for everyone on both
sides of that table and the last thing
that jQuery really solved the boss
problem that it solved was ajax and
before you know you had a standard
jQuery library or API if you will you
know you had to write Ajax for multiple
versions of browsers and identify quirks
in one but not in the other and and
tailor your application to deal with all
that well just by using jQuery you could
abstract above that layer and move on to
doing you know app development working
on what your users wanted and I think
this really drove a large part of the
web forward way back in in period
between like 2005 and 2010 ish where we
we got to the what I call frameworks
part one and this is where the use of
jQuery has proliferated and adopt you
know adopted it been adopted at a
massive scale but it started causing
some of its own problems and if you
notice a pattern here I think it's
something that software development has
always had
may never be able to get away from is
you know you you build the tool that
solves a problem you have and that tool
is useful and it gets used a lot and the
massive use of that tool causes more
problems so you build another tool so
these tools that came about kind of in
this period where some of the early
things that I consider is frameworks you
could call them libraries collections of
utilities the first one I heard about
but never really got deep into using was
something that called knockout J s I
believe it was used or came out of
Microsoft or a Microsoft related project
and it pioneered this idea of model view
viewmodel
pattern a design pattern so anyone whose
is kind of educated themselves in
computer science will know there's all
kinds of design patterns that are useful
but before before this time JavaScript
really didn't have an easy way to apply
those patterns some folks did it because
you know they they figured out how to do
it but it wasn't shared it wasn't
adopted as a standard way of doing
things so knock out kind of identified
this pattern and then wrote some code
that let you create an app with this
pattern in mind and it helped you
abstract your app up a level or to
understand here's the pieces of my app
this is the model this is a view and the
view controller is what kind of glues
them together fast-forward a year or two
and back boom said hey we like what
you're doing maybe but we're gonna do it
a slightly different way I don't know if
they said that but you know you know
what I'm saying is a new tool that was
developed in a similar pattern and it
was the first one that I used in a real
production context but basically the the
library gave context and structure to
help organize the code base and they did
that by providing these three big
building blocks models collections and
views you know models obviously is where
your data will live views is where your
data will show up and be presented and
then the collections wires them together
and in
you know you get to write what happens
and figure out how that behavior works
so that one was was the first one I used
and then the second one that I used
starting I think around 2014 2014 or so
was when I first came across angularjs
just a quick note it is now angularjs
and angular not there's two projects
with the similar name but they're not
the same we'll talk about that in a
minute but angularjs did a similar
similar thing in that they provided the
model view viewmodel
controller pattern but they also said
we're gonna ship this framework with
some opinions you know where it came out
of google by the way and they're very
some very smart engineers there and they
had strong opinions on and how things
should be done how an app should be
constructed so baked into their library
is a very opinionated way of writing a
router for a web a web app you know
writing an HTTP API that is used
throughout the web app writing services
that glue various controllers in your
app together so they they put all that
out there and angular took off in a very
similar way to I think how jQuery took
off and that was good apps we're getting
more functional they were getting more
native-like
but developers were still having
problems while these apps were being
developed and so we had a wide variety
of tooling kind of spring up alongside
these frameworks and kind of evolved
with these frameworks at the same time
there's really four I want to highlight
here because they all sort of signify
significant advances that make the
developer experience in the modern web a
lot better than it used to be the first
one was Sirkin 2011 Ryan Dahl was a his
name I believe he he coded up this idea
of hey I want to run JavaScript on my
own server and so he he released it to
the world and it was this cross-platform
JavaScript runtime the
you could write JavaScript and run it
from your command line on your computer
and that was crazy because before that
you had needed a web browser to do
anything and this sort of gave a lot of
fuel to JavaScript and after that people
started scratching all the different
kinds of itches to make their lives as
developers easier with JavaScript and
they needed somewhere to kind of share
and store those those utilities they
were writing so right after pretty close
after node coming out NPM launched and
eventually was baked into node but it
didn't start they started out as
separate projects but basically it
became this command-line utility that
you could use to search find install
manage this exponentially growing group
of tools and utilities all written in
JavaScript and I'll show a sample
package JSON in a second but fast
forward a couple years and people were
you know really solidifying how
standards work in JavaScript and they
were moving forward but browsers were
still kind of causing a little problem
they weren't adopting them they weren't
shipping browsers that could consume
modern JavaScript constructs so a really
smart fella Evan Lee maybe what's his
name I can't remember his name but the
the creator of Babel basically took that
idea and said I want to write modern
JavaScript languages I want to use it in
a way that makes sense to me that makes
my code easier to understand easier to
architect and I want it to run in some
of these older browsers that don't
understand it and so he wrote this tool
that takes that es6 es7 yeeess next now
whatever version you want to write his
tool will turn that into something that
you know ie11 can run and it's a very
powerful tool and what it does is it
does this thing called transpiling which
i think i generally use the word
compiling all those not completely
accurate but it transpires your source
code
into something that the browser
understands and you know away you go you
you get as a developer you get a better
experience using the modern language but
your your code still works in the
environment that the products live in
and then finally all these things kind
of highlighted the need for this idea of
well how do we okay we can compile it
and create it but how do we actually
optimize it and split it up and get it
ready for this modern web as we realize
you know not all the bits of our
JavaScript are needed right away so how
do we figure out how to do that and
webpack came along after a couple other
sort of orchestration tools were used
for a few years and they basically
helped you package up and optimize your
application for delivery to the web so
real quick this is a sample NPM package
manifest and I want to highlight three
things here that I I think are they're
important to me for understanding what
NPM is and what it does for you it lets
you organize your dependencies which is
turns into a little JavaScript object
and it basically tells you what the name
of your dependency is and tells you what
version you have it have in your project
and dependencies are things that are
going to get packaged up and used inside
your app when it's delivered to the
clients browser it also lets you manage
these things called dev dependencies
because as these frameworks were
evolving and getting more complicated
you know files were getting bigger
we're web pack and grunt and gulp we're
doing things like let's concatenate all
of our JavaScript into one massive file
but now we need to make that file
smaller so there's a bunch of tools that
people wrote to help them automate that
and do that and the dev dependencies you
install will will help along those lines
they'll provide some little effort that
helps automate your app building
experience and typescript is one of
those that I use in the angular projects
I work on and then scripts was one of
the coolest things I think
one of the first things I gravitated to
it in NPM and basically with this
complications that were added to the
build process for an app you needed a
way to not have to remember babel build
command with arguments one and two and
at this file in that file so the scripts
kind of gives you an area where you can
customize the developer experience for
your app it it gives you the ability to
write a shell script if you want write a
node script if you want and then execute
it with a simple npm run my command and
do a lot of complicated things without
having to remember what's going on
except for the first time when you write
write that script so that was a I think
the NPM besides jQuery the NPM evolution
and adoption was a big milestone in in
the JavaScript evolution and finally we
come to frameworks part two and there
are a couple out there I'm not gonna
talk too much about view or Elm there's
a couple others but they're projects
that do you guys use though okay oh
there's a big fan of it on my team but
their projects that kind of built on
what the first generation of frameworks
kind of learned the mistakes they made
they figured out how not to make them
and the good things they kind of carried
them over so react was the the first one
I would consider was like the more
evolved of the frameworks and it was
kind of came out of Facebook in 2013
it's its claim to fame was really they
wanted to well they had a massive scale
for their applications I don't know
there's seven hundred eight hundred
million people back in 2013 maybe a
billion and so they had a really large
data set that needed to get into their
apps and use the data and they had a
couple key principles that I think
helped them manage the the large changes
that were coming down with these massive
data consumptions by client apps and so
they whoops
they they pioneered this concept of
one-way data-binding if you're familiar
with an immutable state they figured out
hey it's a better if if our app knows
there's one source of truth and when
that source of truth changes everybody
gets the update at the same time and the
way they did that is by working with
something called the virtual Dom because
we all know that it's extremely
expensive to query the Dom dig into the
Dom make changes to the Dom what they
said is instead of doing that
let's just take a picture of the Dom
let's see what it looks like and then
when we know there's changes let's take
another picture there's a very
lightweight process and then we'll see
what's different and then we can narrow
in on those small set of changes zoom in
to that part of the the application and
update it when it needs it and it helped
really kind of increase the performance
of apps and helped I think consumers
kind of become really comfortable with
some slick apps that started to approach
a native feel and then angular 2016 so I
mentioned before there's angularjs and
there's angular so the first word in
angular angularjs today kind of was
there was a line drawn in the sand and I
think they had some some lessons that
they learned and they wanted to move
forward but they couldn't move forward
with the legacy code base so it
ultimately ended up being an a complete
rewrite and so you know for developers
like me week I resisted jumping into
angular for a while and then now I'm not
even sure why I hesitated or waited
because a lot of the decisions they made
were really good for my developer
experience but a couple of the things
they did that I think are worth
highlighting is they wrote it in
typescript typescript is a typed
language that is a superset of
JavaScript and it compiles down to
JavaScript even more interesting is that
you can one you can use it in in any
framework if you want but you can target
specific versions of ECMO scripts so you
can say I need my code to run
es 3 because we've got this ancient
thing running on a kiosk in this little
mall
well typescript will help you do that
and give you the tools to write code in
a modern way that can run on browsers
that may have been around 15-20 years
ago the other thing they did was they
can't they instead of using the
immutable pattern they have this idea of
dependency injection which is a I think
a carry over the first time I saw it was
in Java world where you annotate your
classes with other bits of information
so that when you build your app it knows
hey this class needs to know about this
service and a service in angular world
is really just something that's a
singleton that can act as a single
source of truth for an application and
finally the one thing that I think
angular is kind of doing better than
even react but react has something
similar that's making pretty quick
strides is they have this idea of the
angular CLI so the angular CLI is a tool
that lets you create a new app with one
command line process and it will let you
add a component and what it's doing
under the hood is it's writing all this
boilerplate out to the file so that you
don't have to create a new class you
don't have to tell your app module about
that class because things have gotten a
lot more complicated this is a tool that
helps kind of alleviate some of that
complications so that's that's what I
have for the history lesson I'm going to
jump over to my computer and kind of
walk through that timer app and we'll
see how it goes miss it sorry
thank you so is that big enough can
everyone see if it's too small let me
just shout out and I'll bump it up so we
have here what I'm calling a native
timer app and we're gonna look at it in
es5 ish syntax this is something that I
would have written 2000-2005 maybe maybe
earlier if you look at the structure of
the project you have an index you have a
source we're gonna ignore this I wasn't
sure if I'd have internet access so I
didn't want to uninstall my node modules
you have this idea of assets where I
just put an image and a CSS file but you
might have had another folder for images
another file for folder for styles if
you had a more complicated web page you
might have multiple ones of those but I
think you get the idea that it was it
was pretty simple is an easy structure
to understand and in order to run this
app all you had to do was deliver it to
a web server and clients just needed to
go to the web URL and they're good to go
so my timer has some requirements let me
talk about those real quick so basically
we need to start the timer we need to
stop the timer we need to mark times and
list them out somewhere we need to tell
the user when the timer is running and
we need to tell the user when they've
added a time to their list and the way I
did this in es5 is you know we have a
simple HTML document and we add in our
style we add in our script which we'll
get to in a minute and in between there
we we have an element we call app and
that app has three parts I if anyone
knows how to get rid of those things in
PS code let me know because the things
that pop up I don't okay I'll have to
look because it's been bugging me for a
couple days but there's three sections
there's the timer display where we show
the the current time then there's the
the buttons that let the user start/stop
mark do do whatever they need to do and
then we have a list for each each time
that we want to record and make note of
so the way I I kind of went back to the
early days is at least as far as I could
remember them is I I wrote it all in one
script you know I had to know if it was
running so I gave it a global State I
had to know where my app was so I used
the the native web api's to get the
element and get a reference to it then I
created a function that I could pass
element to and if you look closely at
the code you'll obviously see there's
some room for optimizing and refactoring
it a bit but when you call this function
it passes an element that is used in a
couple different places to add in the
time that is the current one for our
calculations and then we have a couple
functions that we can use to attach to
elements for starting the timer
resetting the timer marking the timer
resetting the the timer and so that's
kind of all encapsulated in a function
and this is probably even more advanced
than 95 to 2000 JavaScript was written
but it was worth encapsulating for the
purposes of this but then in order to
get that functionality on to my elements
I had to bind those functions to them
somehow and the the way we have today is
the web api for add eventlistener
so I can isolate the click events and
then add a function that does some stuff
it checks the global state which we all
know is a bad thing but you know we use
the tools we have it adds it adds a
class list to this app variable that if
you remember is defined up top where we
we know
kind of what that reference is - and
finally it it does a it sets an interval
that calls the start timer function
every hundred milliseconds and if you
remember that timer function all it's
doing is you know looking at what the
current time is figuring out how much
time has passed and kind of formatting
that that a little that number a little
bit so that we can have a decimal in our
user interface and and that was that was
kind of the extent of the early
JavaScript projects that I could come
across is there was a lot of want this
functionality and we need to do it this
way and so you you kind of threw it all
into one file you tried to avoid global
state if you could but you usually had
something that couldn't be isolated and
so it ended up in there and and it
caused you know enough problems that
JavaScript evolved past that and jQuery
came along and I don't have an example
with jQuery I'm going to move right to
turning this code into es syntax so it's
going to look very similar but it's
worth highlighting that that's what
drove you know the react and the
angular's frameworks for today so if we
check out the es6 app the built-in one
for built in one for vs code i use the c
shell and i forget with some theme with
whatever something i customized once
years ago and forgot about so now you'll
notice i have a similar structure to the
es5 app but the index is gone I now have
a package JSON that lets me take
advantage of what NPM brings in to the
developer experience I have this gate
ignore just tells me tells me I have one
not to care about for version control
and there's this babble RC which is an
object that babel uses and this is where
I tell babble here's what I want to do
this code and I'm telling them use this
es2015 presets and when you compile the
code I'm writing for distribution
include source maps in there so if I run
babel without doing anything else it
will look for this file and it'll use
those pre-configured presets to generate
output code you'll notice there's a
there's no assets oh oh oh
interesting I hope I didn't mess it up
oh I forgot to show the es5 app running
but I don't remind me to show this one
running I'll show it in a minute
and now I'm not sure why that's there
alright so in our source we have what
you could consider the structure of our
application everything outside of it is
some sort of dependency that we need to
build the app and deliver it so we still
have our index it still looks like the
same HTML structure but we put our
assets inside there we have some images
in a stylesheet and then we have an
application that with is with a Saturday
afternoon of time to do all these demos
I turn into something that's es6 so
basically the biggest difference here is
that I remove the global state from the
application and I wrapped it into a
single class and I put as much
functionality in that class as possible
and using es6 i can do a lot of things
in the constructor when someone
initializes a new a new instance of this
timer app we can do a bunch of things
ahead of time and say you find this find
this element and give me a reference to
it find this other element give me a
reference to it and that instance of the
timer can now work isolated by itself in
the browser and not worry about stepping
on other bits of JavaScript Stowe's we
still add an event listener and bind
them to click handlers one thing to note
is I had to pass
this which if anyone who's done a lot of
JavaScript development they'll know
scoping is a mysterious and dark art but
basically passing that in let's my
function run and understand what its
state is I try to keep it as minimal as
possible for this demonstration this is
pure vanilla JavaScript as possible and
then notice that these these click
handlers are inside encapsulated inside
my class and they do basically the same
thing they add a class if it's running
they have a check and they set an
interval to calculate the new time they
have a way to stop the timer remove the
interval so that the timer stops and
invite in etc we can reset the app we
can mark the time and so then I now have
a nice encapsulated bit of code that I
can initialize in my global state with a
new simple variable in a function call
it says hey I want a new timer so to see
what this looks like running I apologize
for not showing the es5 it looks the
same though except for the background
image so if we open up that we open it
up we get a nice little app we have some
buttons we can start our timer and I
broke it no no let's go back to the es5
one I'll show you running there I'm
sorry about that I do not like live
coding if it if it's at all possible but
kid check yeah
all right so we have a timer I can start
it I can tell the user is running I can
mark some laps when I mark a lap I let
them know hey it's running I can stop
the timer one thing to know it is I
could still add times and that's
probably a bug
you wouldn't want multiple things of the
exact same value in your collection so I
could write a bunch of code to kind of
look at that array and figure out do I
put it in or not put it in or just put
everything in there and figure out will
only show the unique things but you know
modern JavaScript gives us things like
sets which we know you know is a data
structure let's just put in one unique
thing and if you try to put another
thing in it doesn't even error for you
it just says thanks know and goes on
about its way so I'll show you that in
the angular app basically to fix this
bug so that's the app it resets and that
kind of takes us up to these modern
frameworks where there's a bunch of
tooling and so what I'm about to show in
the angular app is gonna be a little
more complicated I'll try to hit these
high-level you know what's the global
state look like what's the Dom
manipulation for angular look like and
then what's the event binding and how
would you get this app to production so
if we go back to code alright I have
this thing called an angular timer and
so if you haven't worked at angular
before has anyone worked with angular
here before all right so not a whole lot
so I'll try to kind of help you
understand how the project is organized
again we have a JSON file and you'll
notice that it it has a couple scripts I
generated this app with angular CLI so I
didn't actually write any of this it
gives me something that I can use to
start my application which has a
built-in local development server so
that gives me the ability to do things
like write code save and it
automatically reloads my browser so that
by the time I flip over from my editor
to the web browser I already see my code
running or not running in the web
browser
linting is basically a way of keeping
your code clean to certain preset
configurations of like oh you should
always have a semicolon or should always
indent two spaces etc so they bake that
into the app generation for the angular
CLI tool and then ete is is end end
testing they have another framework that
is useful for testing angular
applications there's a bunch of other
projects out there that you can kind of
dig into if you're use Cades are
different that are have their own sort
of use cases and fans for following but
you see here in our dependencies we have
a bunch of angular stuff we have this
core j/s we have this rxjs and we have
the zone GS all the angular stuff is
what makes angular work for me and the
other stuff are things that angular
depends on if you're not familiar with
rxjs I'd say that's one of the coolest
things I've really had to dive into in
the last couple years it's worth it's
worth learning if you ever went from
jQuery callback hell - oh my god
promises are awesome you'll you'll be a
fan of observables when you when you get
into them as worth noting there and then
all these dev dependencies this is how
we build and ship this app in an
optimized way for production so
everything that the angular CLI needs to
build my app is installed in my node
modules and then when I run the the
write command it packages it all up it
optimizes it and it gets it ready for me
to do something with so that's the
package the code itself angular needs to
know a couple things about my app and I
can change them and configure them as I
need to but basically it has a
configuration object the main things to
see here is this prefix and schematics
prefix is something that we'll use so
every component I build in an angular
app will basically be very similar to a
web component so it'll have its own HTML
like signature where I can bracket app -
timer closed closed bracket and then
close close that like you would close
any other div or section or whatever but
this tells app when you create new
components prepend this app so if I want
to customize that for my uses I just
change it there everything that gets
generated gets that prefix and then
schematics is something that I haven't
seen anybody else doing this but it's
this idea that I think angular wants to
make it really easy to update and
maintain client applications so the
clarity project that I work on is a UI
library it's it's a module it's not an
app and our customers kind of depend on
us to keep breaking changes to a minimum
or not include them at all unless we're
bumping a major version and this
schematics is a tool that lets you work
within the angular ecosystem and say ng
add at CLR angular and it'll install
this tool the the clarity angular
components it will also we also have the
ability to say hey we know this is an
angular application instead of you
having to go and put our clarity module
into the application we'll do that for
you we know where it goes we'll import
it we'll add that and when you use our
components it's all ready for you to go
you don't have to do that boilerplate
configuration yourself the other really
powerful thing that the schematics does
for me as a library maintainer is that
when I do have breaking changes or
deprecations
and you install my project with angular
CLI I can scan your codebase and say hey
this thing you're using is deprecated in
this version and I can write in a custom
note for here look here and see how long
it's going to be in you know in the
clarity library look see when we're
going to remove it even more powerful if
it's not too complicated of a change and
we deprecated something and you don't
update it when you install it with the
schematics I can provide a template for
hey you're using this old thing turn it
into the new thing so that deprecations
or removals magically get handled or
notified hey you're installing a version
that this thing no longer
and your apps gonna horribly break and
we want to let you know about it as soon
as possible
so that's a very powerful thing that
schematics brings to the angular
ecosystem so real quick what that looks
like is as I said angular is a tree of
components and so you start with a root
component and the way you you get that
started is kind of glossing over the
bootstrapping process is we still have
an HTML file but it gets really simple
you notice there's no Styles there's no
scripts so when we build the app angular
CLI and all the and web pack is actually
the build tool underneath there
it's configured good enough for 90% of
the use cases if you really need to you
can eject out of the default
configuration and customize it but I
don't see the need for my uses but what
I want to say was our our app get
started with this custom like element
called app root and we have a component
and you'll notice we have a selector
called app root so when angular comes
across this element it knows what it is
it knows what template to apply to it
and it knows what style to go with it
and there's a couple different ways to
do it but the default version of angular
encapsulate all that capsule Eight's all
of that CSS in a way that makes style
conflicts impossible so the names that I
use for this component and this
stylesheet couldn't ever conflict with
something else some somewhere in the the
webpage of the application you'll notice
there's not a whole lot going on here we
just have this app root in this template
so if we look into that template it'll
kind of feel like we're starting to walk
into a tree where we have another
another custom like element called app
timer and that's really the meat of what
it took to turn that es6 code into an
angular app and I basically had to have
four components
I had the timer component and well look
at the code in
we have the the button bar we have the
display and we have the mark list so if
you remember those basic div elements we
had they basically become first-class
citizens of my app they can have their
own encapsulated style their own
encapsulated functionality and the tools
that angular provides gives me the
ability to manage global state with
basically in an angular app you don't
really need global state you can
encapsulate all that state inside the
typescript files and kind of work
confidently inside there so for
something like Dom manipulation if we
look at the timer display which is the
big number of what the current time is
you'll see we'll start with a template
this time and this could have been in
line into the typescript code but I
apologize I was a little too lazy to to
do that but for smaller templates
gentlemenly five to ten lines or less
I'll inline them into the typescript
file itself anything that gets bigger
it's worth kind of separating it out it
gets too complicated and there's two
things going on here we'll come back to
time format but basically in my in my
timer display component class there's a
variable called current time and
whatever that current time is it will
get interpolated in this template with
that value
the other thing angular will do for me
is it will pass that value to this time
format function which I'll show you real
quick and kind of explain at a high
level what it is and what it does for me
so then we have the component itself and
you'll see it follows a similar pattern
we have you know we import the stuff we
need from angular we import our timer
service which we'll talk about in a
minute and then we we decorate our
component with these this metadata for
what selector is used what template is
used with this class and what style goes
along with it and angular does the work
of packaging that all up encapsulating
it and delivers it to your browser and
our class looks pretty simple remember
we have that current time property and
we have two things going on here
back to the timer service remember how I
said you know Dom manipulation and data
binding and things that jQuery kind of
brought to the table well angular has
this idea of decorators and so that
component is a decorator at host binding
as a decorator because angular views
this class as the host anything that
lives inside there in terms of an HTML
template is is a child of the house it's
a view as part of the view for that host
and so when I use the @ host binding
decorator angular knows hey when this
clot this thing is true add the class
timer display to this host so in my
browser
I'll have this app timer display element
and it'll have class equals timer
display and now I can target CSS for
that host and and write things that I
want it to do the other thing that's
going on here is remember how I we we
talked about not having global state but
we still need to maintain state for our
app and pass it around so angular uses
that rxjs project and it basically gives
me the ability to create a stream of
time events and if you're familiar with
rxjs
it's basically what I'm doing is
subscribing to an observable that
basically passes every new time to
whoever subscribes to it so in this case
I subscribe to new times and whenever
they're generated I hear about them and
whenever I hear about them I run this
lambda function inline that sets the new
time value to this dot current time and
we show up in our browser it's similar
it's not Redux though it's not one-way
flow same idea it's it's it's components
listening to a state but I could give a
whole 20 30 minutes in how the angular
providers are organized at a high level
these providers are
a tree so angular gives you this thing
called an injector and you can put
providers in there so if you put it high
enough up the tree your providers
available to the entire app but if I I
say hey I want to define my provider at
a lower level at this component level
then you'll notice where is that if we
go back to highlight that if you look at
my timer component you notice that I
decorated my metadata with this timer
service so I only only inject it into
this timer component but when I want to
use it in my where is it timer display I
don't have to provide it again because
if I did that I'd end up with two
instances angular would say oh you want
one here and you want one here so it
instantiate two different providers and
they're two different states so by
injecting it up top and then inject and
then putting it into the constructor
angular knows about it it knows what
type it is it gives me access to it and
then lets me subscribe to that single
state so does that answer your question
it's kind of multi-layered you can do
global or you can target it that state
where you want to target it and then
observables work the way observables
work so it's different than that
so I said a just to click right so I set
an interval and so every hundred
milliseconds it called that function
called that function and then when I
stopped it I basically wiped the
interval out and it stops we can look at
that so so my service is a little messy
it needs some cleaning up but basically
this starts getting into what is rxjs
and how does it work but we have the
subjects which is the single source of
truth and then I give access to those
subjects those subjects with this public
get time method it returns something
with a type observable and basically it
returns that time stream dot observe as
observable so whoever subscribes to that
will hear about changes on the where the
timestream behavior subject the
difference between a behavior subject
and a subject is that a subject
initializes and that's it a behavior
subject takes a value and initializes
with that value so if someone's
subscribed to it when they subscribe to
it they get that first value so
basically I want to populate 0.00 as my
first timer value the way I add changes
to it is I where do I do that
so when you start the timer if we're
running the time calculation we tell
some people that were running so whoever
subscribes to this running behavior
subject will get the next event in that
stream and then for the time calculation
I set this interval same same principle
as before and I run the cup I calculate
the next time and then I update this
this this is the way that people hear
about the message
that I'm sending when I get the next
time I add it to this timestream next
function and so no matter how many
subscribers there are to this property
they all get the same time from that
observable does that help yeah that's so
I it's not a perfect timer yeah yeah
there yeah yeah there's delay but it's
pretty reliable in terms of propagating
out without yeah no it's very consistent
yeah right
right all right so what are we looking
at so da a little more Dom manipulation
and if we get too late I can wrap it up
but if you're good I can keep going okay
so we talked a little about the timer
display let's talk about event binding
so we have our buttons and it's just we
kind of took out that little bit of
functionality from the es6 app and now
we need to bind some functionality to
our user interface and we don't want to
use at event listener so angular it
gives you this convention of tying and
tying into the native browser events so
as you'll see here click is a native
browser event and by putting parentheses
around it this tells angular hey listen
to the click event for this element and
when it hears something run this
function which is defined in my
typescript class so it works for you
know mouse over Mouse move you know any
any event that's a native one you can
use and you can write your own custom
events that kind of notify hey something
happened so there's there's a lot of
flexibility in using what's already
there but kind of customizing it for
your needs later if we look at the
typescript class you'll see you know
there's the metadata for the decorator
we inject our service but we don't do
anything in the constructor what we do
is we we use those bound functions to
tell the time or hey start the timer
hey timer service stop the timer
so we can very nicely kind of break out
the pieces that need access to that
timer service that global state and keep
our our component class is focused on
what its job is and the only job of the
the timer bar is to start stop mark and
reset and that's event binding we'll
talk about I think the last thing to
really talk about is how would I get
this to production but before we do that
let's just show it running so you can
kind of see that I do have a functional
application so remember the package.json
it gave me that and that list of
commands they basically run the CLI
which tells it hey they want to serve
this app so it goes and looks at
everything I've configured it finds all
my files it stuffs them all together and
it starts a dev server for me and I can
see running angular app that is a timer
you'll notice it works pretty similar to
the other ones we can mark times for our
laps we can stop times you'll notice I
can't add more than one number of the
same time and basically I use the
JavaScript set which does all the work
of keeping values unique for my use case
so I don't have the right extra the nice
thing for me is that modern contract
means I don't have to write extra error
handling code I don't have to worry
about that if I kind of pick the right
tool for the job I'm trying to do and
that's it so that's the developers
experience but the the
I pushed to the the set well I think
when it compiles down it's an array but
it's got a lot of it does all the duping
and unique of the values so that my
array only ends up with the right values
so you're familiar with the concept of a
set right adding an item to the set and
then it notifies hey there's a new item
and the user interface populates I can
go into oh no what did I do okay sorry
[Music]
alright alright so here's that that mark
list component and it's the consumer of
that set so I already know I'm getting
unique values and basically I subscribe
to that stream and I update my timer
list whenever I hear a new thing on that
stream the way I get it into the user
interface is the template actually does
change from the the es5 es6 one
basically angular gives us this idea of
iterators so any templating language
you're familiar with has had something
similar but there's this idea of a
structural directive and what that means
in angular world is that anything with
an asterisks is a directive on an
element and that tells angular it's
going to actually modify it's gonna
create and destroy elements at some
point in an angular application
lifecycle you can have directives that
don't do that they just add behavior but
because we're gonna actually
conditionally create a list depending on
how many elements are in our time array
I know I need a structural directive and
angular gives us this ng four so four
four every time in my timer list it will
stamp out a list item for me and then
I'm good I don't have to do anything
else the last thing I forgot to show too
is this formatting remember how I was
formatting all the time strings based on
the function it was running well that's
kind of not use reusable or sustainable
if I want to change that format I've got
to change it in a bunch of places
angular gives this idea of pipes and so
a pipe is something that I can put into
my HTML and then it's a function that
basically receives the the information
so whatever's maps are current time gets
passed to this function I write my
formatting here and I reuse it in my
HTML wherever I need to and when I want
to update my format I update here and in
one place and everybody gets it
so the last thing I have to show here is
production so the webpack app the es5
app was easy to get into production the
webpack app would need some earth beside
the es6 app would need some web pack
you'd have to configure it and get it
ready to you know concatenates angular
CLI gives me a tool build and if I give
it this command prod while it's running
what prod does is it does all those
optimizations but it also if you're
familiar with how web pack is really
revolutionising something that we're
calling tree shaking so angular at Build
time analyzes my app and looks at stuff
to make sure it's used used if there's
something in there that's not used it
removes it from the bundle that gets
shipped for production thus making my
file smaller my app a little more
performant my user a little happier
developers are happy too because if
you're using the CLI they've configured
web pack for all that and you just have
to type the right flag and you're off
and going so that's all I have for the
demo here so that's that's it I think we
kind of went through these three stages
we we looked at you know where ACMA
script sort of pushed the evolution of
javascript yes three es four years five
you know it was a wild wild west back
then there was a lot of issues that
tooling and jquery es6 came along and
you know helped address and then finally
the the idea of a framework or a library
to work cohesively to use modern design
patterns to bring that all together they
you know have addressed a lot of those
needs there's a variety of them out
there I think they're all worth kind of
knowing a little bit about because you
never know what's gonna be the next
jQuery angularjs angular or react which
are I'll react
massively adopted I have one more thing
but I do yeah I do think it's worth kind
of understanding those at a high level
no matter what you're using in your day
to day so if you're interested in the
apps they are up on github in a
repository feel free to take a look I
hope this was useful I hope it took you
maybe down to some fond memories or not
so fond memories but this was sort of my
journey through JavaScript as I
understand it and that's all I have
[Applause]
[Music]
you